we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P here's another voicemail
about my appearance on the Patrick Bet
David podcast
Steven it's Alan from Jersey yeah I
don't know what the heck is going on
with you but you're on some weird PB and
J podcast in this right TV and Jake guy
is like Joe Rogan except
he's exactly like Joe Rogan except he
has hair okay and you're trying to tell
him how you were scamming people into
buying the the extra insurance at
Circuit City
and he doesn't want to talk about that I
mean what the hell's going on with you
David I mean you're moving to Florida
now you're swimming with the dolphins
you're gonna move into the villages and
with Pat and well listen I'm not going
to The Villages but I have to tell you
there is something very appealing very
appealing about getting out of the cold
for two to three months out of the year
maybe I'll become a snowbird but if I
did it's gonna have to be Southern
Florida I don't see myself as a
Jacksonville guy
um but uh as far as the pbd appearance
we'll be publishing the whole thing to
our YouTube channel very soon and I look
forward to getting more great feedback
about it pbd is Joe Rogan with hair
though is an interesting one we've got a
great bonus show for you today sign up
at joinpakman.com don't miss it I will
see you then